hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll there's a great scene in the big
bang theory i'm thinking of the sitcom
not the scenario for the cosmological
origin of the universe but in the big
bang theory they have a scene where
they're trying to dramatize
theoretical physicists doing their work
now the problem is the radical
physicists just sort of often stand in
front of a blackboard silently thinking
so that's exactly what they show in the
sitcom but they play eye of the tiger in
the background to make it seem very very
dramatic and then there's some cuts from
different angles and so forth the joke
of course is that the work of
theoretical physics or doing math or
related things is just not very
cinematic it does not lend itself very
well to being shown on the screen but
that is a challenge undertaken by
today's guest david goyer i'm sure you
know david's work he is a screenwriter
storyteller a novelist comic book writer
who has been involved in things like the
dark knight trilogy
uh man of steel and batman v superman
blade terminator as well as being the
co-writer for video games like the call
of duty series and so forth and his most
recent project ongoing right now is a
multi-season adaptation of isaac
asimov's foundation stories which is
currently being shown on apple tv so for
those of you who don't know the
foundation series started back in the
1940s it's the story of the fall of the
galactic empire
i think one of the first stories
involving a galactic empire although
they've obviously been other ones since
then and the
conceit is that a future mathematician
named harry selden has invented a way to
use math to basically predict the future
of large-scale civilizations the idea
being that just like you can ignore the
motions of individual molecules if you
want to predict the motions of a fluid
you can ignore the idiosyncrasies of
individual humans if you want to predict
the future of a society so the
foundation series as it was originally
written there's a lot of scenes in there
of math being done or talked about or
argued about and so forth and it's
almost like given ahead of time what's
going to happen the math will always win
so this is a special challenge for an
adapter and it's a very interesting test
case because you should watch the show i
i personally have seen the first season
and i think it's wonderful but uh you
know your tastes may differ it the
adaptation is not the same as the book
they take many many liberties let's just
put it that way i consider it to be a
separate work that is extremely
successful in its own right but it's
very challenging you got to watch it
there's a lot of moving parts a lot of
different stories and one of the
problems with adapting foundation the
original stories were a collection of
stories unrelated to each other in terms
of characters or places in the universe
so you have to make that into something
that is a little bit of a through line
where you can follow characters and
everything i had no idea how they were
going to do that and they pulled that
off extremely successfully as well as
making the math exciting and of course
adding in some sex scenes and some
starship battles just to make it
cinematic and fun to watch on the screen
so i talked with david both about
general challenges of adapting big
science fiction stories like this and
the specific ways in which science and
math come into these kinds of
adaptations where you take them on and
learn something from them and where you
have to bend the rules just a little bit
for the sake of the story it's something
we all gotta do
uh occasional reminder you know we have
a website here for the podcast you can
go to preposterousuniverse.com
podcast every episode has show notes and
links and you can get full transcripts
of all the episodes and of course we
also have a patreon if you're interested
in supporting mindscape you can go to
patreon.com sean m carroll that's the
way that you can get to ask questions
for the ask me anything episodes and
also you get ad-free versions of the
podcast so do that to support mindscape
sign up for apple tv if you haven't
already to support foundation and let's
go
[Music]
david goyer welcome to the mindscape
podcast
thanks for having me i'm i'm a bit
there's a little bit of trepidation uh
not being a scientist myself um
i'm worried i'm gonna uh
tank your signal to noise ratio uh in
terms of quality guests but we'll see
what happens we love it you're an expert
in your domain you're a domain expert as
we say so that's completely fair
um but so the first obvious question i
have to ask is you know you've been
responsible for
telling stories on tv and film about
batman and superman and the terminator
and now asimov's foundation series neil
gaiman's sandman series so the obvious
question is how big of a glutton for
punishment are you
in telling these stories that already
have huge fan bases with very very
specific uh requirements and
expectations
well it's it's funny because um
there's a there's a there's a pithy
answer and a serious answer and i'll
give you both of them um
i mean i've i'm fortunate enough that
i've been doing this uh quite a long
time i sold my first screenplay when i
was 21 and it was made as a film when i
was 22. i'm over 50 now so i've been in
the game over 30 years
and
you know
you we've all heard about 10 000 hours
and whatnot uh and i think that the
you know the the longer you're in it um
you want to be challenged more and and
and uh there's no question that this is
something
well i i did pass on it in my 30s and
then again in my 40s foundation um but
after having um
done some trickier adaptations um i i
felt i was up for the challenge and i
also felt i was mature enough to do it
but the
the other answer in terms of adaptations
it's funny i didn't set out to become
the guy that adapts tricky
properties but i've sort of become known
as that now amongst hollywood is like oh
this thing's really hard to crack get
going or we need to reinvent this thing
get goier
um but the the other thing that's funny
right now as um
all of the
uh
tv
um you know you're seeing this
consolidation now um with all the
streamers this vertical integration
right and and one of the things that's
sad is
increasingly
as everyone's fighting for a slice of
the pie they're they're interested in
pre-existing ips so it's harder to sell
and set up original projects
particularly expensive ones because they
believe
that some kind of
pre-association
means that they have a better chance at
making a profit frankly and i mean of
course i know that's true and i guess it
makes sense to me but surely they
realize that all these pre-existing
projects or ips did start somewhere as
non-pre-existing
ideas well of course of course no i mean
it it doesn't it doesn't make sense
because
then you'll get an original
um
you know
film or you know television yeah no i i
mean it's i i think it's kind of
circular reasoning frankly but um you
know this is what they tell themselves
and i can just tell you anecdotally
trying to set up an original now
is much more difficult than when i began
and that's too bad but i mean on the
other hand maybe there is just a more
complicated ecosystem where we field
test things in graphic novels or just
regular novels to see
get some of the kinks worked out before
we spend 200 million
the farm team yeah yeah
yes yes
it's funny though because it can extend
to almost you know
um ridiculous extremes for instance you
could have a tiny tiny comic book that
might have sold
literally three thousand copies but
because it's a pre-existing idea oh well
well well gosh darn it uh this is a hot
property and then hollywood's convinced
that they can make a billion dollars off
of it as a feature film interesting to
know for any of the i always like to you
know give our audience little tidbits so
if there's any you know young film
producers or screenwriters out there
that that is definitely something to
keep in mind uh why don't you tell us
why do you set up for the folks who are
not fans of isaac asimov's classic
series of novels you know what is
foundation why is this an important uh
story to tell
well
you know with a larger audience i think
this slice of our audience that are
people who are not fans who have not
read the books is is quite large
but i think in terms of your listeners i
i would venture that most of your
listeners have actually very read
so you know the pyramids inverted
foundation
started as a series of short stories
written by isaac asimov um
[Music]
for uh astounding science fiction and
the late 40s and early 50s
asimov was a very young writer trying to
just break into the game i i think it
was in his early 20s when he was writing
the first um short stories eventually
the first six stories were collected
into
a novel
and the premise is he was he was
interested in the the law of mass action
he was interested uh he was studying the
uh well he was always an avid fan of
history but he was just um interested in
the decline in fall of the roman empire
reading gibbons um
and and he was fascinated with the
concept of statistics that if given a
large enough sample size
um one could predict the broad movements
of history social science and so the
premise is
you know x amount of thousands of years
in the future there's a galactic
civilization a galactic empire
and one mathematician a man named harry
selden has come up with a predictive
model called psycho history which does
just that it predicts the broad
movements of history can't predict the
individual person's lifeline or action
but it can predict the broad movements
of history and he predicts that the
empire is going to fall
and fall quickly and he can't do
anything uh
the
empire is too far gone right uh some
would obviously make you know um
analogies to what's happening today in
terms of climate change uh but
um so he can't stop it no one can stop
it uh and if we do nothing uh humanity
will fall into 35 000 years of chaos
however if we follow his plan
we can shorten the age of darkness to a
thousand years
and
and um the first short stories are
are anthological we jump forward you
know 50 60 100 years in time between
characters and by the time
uh these became popular
he
settled in progressively into a series
of novels and and uh but it's
interesting because asimov himself
never made it to the end of the thousand
years he wrote an original trilogy i
believe the third book was published in
1952
in the 80s uh people asked him to write
some more he wrote two sequels he
couldn't figure out how to end the damn
thing so he went back and wrote two
prequels and then he passed away i think
he only got about 578 years into the
thousand
years so the the the the uh the future
is yet unwritten i'm a big fan of you
know the original trilogy i have to say
you know just being extremely candid
here
the prequels man i just did not like
very much i thought that he he had
become so facile with writing that the
original stories you know you know as
you say yourself like the fall of the
galactic empire is a few sentences
whereas in the later books it's like
every coffee shop conversation is 5 000
words so there's got to be some happy
medium in there
yeah you know it's funny
the the other thing that he did asimov
was he he sort of retroactively
uh in the prequels decided to tie the
foundation universe foundation books
into the irobot universe
the
the irobot universe was not part of
foundation and he kind of retroactively
tried to create some kind of grand
unified azimovian you know field theory
where he tied a lot of his works
together
um
it depends i mean there are there are
people that like the original trilogy
there are people that adore the prequels
and sequels as well you are not alone
amongst um
in fact some fairly famous literati who
i will not name who who love the
original trilogy but don't like the
prequels and sequels um i think
i think there are elements in the
prequels and sequels that are
interesting and in fact for this
particular adaptation we pulled some
characters from the prequels into the
present so it was sort of a mix and
match
and did you ever meet asimov
no i didn't he he passed away in the mid
80s ironically of aids uh
as a result of a blood transfusion never
met him
um
would have loved to have met him uh got
to meet ray bradbury a couple of times
that's cool so i i
sort of hold him in the same regard
uh never asimov um
but uh his daughter who's the in charge
of the asimov estate is an executive
producer on the show and um we liaise
quite frequently and of course i had to
i had to um pitch the
my adaptation to her and run various
things by her so she's as close as i've
gotten i did actually get to meet uh
asimov a couple times he was hilariously
funny guy he's a recorder you know he
was well into his uh grand old man stage
right and he was a lot of fun to talk to
but you know as you mentioned back when
he was writing the original uh it was a
trilogy first um
it was a series of stories and
furthermore it was disconnected stories
it was not even the same characters in
the different stories so obviously
uh there's challenges here in
adapting it and i'll be very very honest
i've seen the first season and when i
heard that it was being adapted i
wondered how i would do it and i was
like nope i couldn't do it
it would have to be different characters
in every episode it's just impossible
and you so you but you did not that did
not stop you you really uh invented a
number of clever ways to make it seem
like a connected story
well it's it if you read interviews with
asimov
uh like i said originally he was just
throwing anything against the wall that
would stick he was trying to make his
way as a writer um
and
so he pitched this idea for the um
for the first foundation story he didn't
know if it would work or not and
eventually it worked and
and his editor campbell said well why
don't you do another one he wrote
another one but he didn't go into it
planning it as if it were going to be
some kind of
you know unified series perhaps if
someone had said here's a contract to
write a novel yeah uh at the beginning
he might have constru well in fact
azeroth said he would have constructed a
different story uh but but
um he was just making it up as he was
going along that's what it does and
it was only by the time he got to the
third now yeah yeah it was only by the
time that he got to the third novel
that that it was actually written as a
novel in fact the second novel is are
are two
disconnected novelettes but um yeah that
was the
there were two primary issues three
primary issues one the books are
fascinating but they're dry
uh uh almost all the action happens off
screen uh the empire falls off screen
um
they're not uh there aren't any
character arcs certainly in the first
two books that you know the characters
don't grow and change
um and that's difficult when you're
doing a television adaptation
um and as you said uh in the short
stories um silver harden is in two
stories but beyond that doesn't exist
harry is in the first story and then
exists as a recording in a couple of the
subsequent stories
and there's there's no continuity beyond
that
um
and
um
so it was
you know how do we address all these
those things also the fact that you know
foundation was an influence obviously on
lucas for star wars it was an influence
on herbert for dune and so some of these
ideas have already been strip mined
uh and in um and so the idea of a
galactic empire is not something new
when people think of it the the general
audience they think of star wars so we
had to also figure out ways to make
what was all new again or seem fresh um
but what i think one of the things that
you're alluding to in terms of the
adaptation which was the key for me was
how do i take
asimov's themes
and and express them through character
exactly yeah
and so
we had this notion of a galactic empire
that was resistant to change that um
it's fall is predicted there's nothing
they could that they can do about it
i
wanted
the empire to be embodied in the
character which it's not in the books or
at least in the original trilogy it's
not and um i thought okay well how do i
come up with an embodiment of empire
that's resistant to change
and that led me to the idea of the
genetic dynasty which is a concept
that's not in the books and it's the
idea that
this one character cleon the first about
400 years prior to the pilot decides to
keep cloning himself over and over again
and at any one time there's three of him
on the throne it's the triple throne
there's one of him as
a 30 year old man and one is a 60 year
old man and one is a 90 year old man and
the younger one
brother dawn is an emperor in training
uh the middle one brother day is is is
the ruling emperor
and um brother dusk the older one is the
the sort of um advisor the consequery
and and i thought
wow what could be
you know a better expression of being
resistant to change than literally
trying to clone yourself over and over
again and pose your ego one man across
an entire galaxy and so
and at the same time it allowed me to
cast three characters that we could make
a deal with that would appear in
episodes after episodes right and but
then so that
started from a place of necessity
and then it led to these
you know
oddly i think for the audience to feel
empathy for these monsters um it led us
to tell all these interesting stories
about nature versus nurture because even
though
they're ostensibly monsters
they're also tragic they're all
desperately trying to individuate and
they're living in the shadow of cleon
the first uh of of you know this great
man um so
that was um
that was the key and then i said well
how can i sort of apply that process
to other ideas and you know to other
themes
your home isn't just a place to exist
it's an extension of who you are enjoy
bird can help you create a space that
reflects your personality with modern
customizable furniture and now joybird's
sleep in sale is here at troybird
ordering furniture online has never been
easier or more fun you can choose from
over 18 000 customization options or
browse curated collections to find the
perfect piece for your one-of-a-kind
style joybird is committed to creating
quality furniture and a more sustainable
future each piece is made with
incredible care using responsibly
sourced materials free of harmful
chemicals through partnerships with
groups like one tree planted joybird is
helping conserve and restore earth's
most precious natural resources quality
craftsmanship stainless scratch
resistant fabrics and limited lifetime
warranty joybird furniture can handle
anything your family throws at it
literally enjoy bird stands by its
quality and craftsmanship you get 90 day
returns if it's not everything you hoped
for send it back so create a space that
brings you joy with joy bird visit
joybird.com
mindscape and get thirty percent off
your purchase that's thirty percent off
at j o y b i r d dot com slash mindscape
so i actually also saw by contrast dune
the other night another big major
adaptation that just came out and it's
interesting because i think dune is in
like
most adaptations of these sprawling
works the question is what do you leave
out whereas here with foundation you
have a pretty sprawling work to start
with but you're adding things to it i
mean that must be a different challenge
you have to sort of think about the
themes and being true to the original
material in a different way
yeah it's interesting that you say that
because
you know twice prior to this people that
were attempting to attempt foundation
were attempting to do it as a movie or a
series of movies and when i was
approached in my 30s to adapt it i was
approached by bob shay who was running
new line who'd done the lord of the
rings
had produced the lord of the rings films
and he wanted to do something similar
with foundation he wanted to make a
trilogy of films
uh adapting it and he approached me and
said come on it worked with lord of the
rings and ironically even in three films
they had to condemn some things and cut
some characters out and i said
i don't think it can work with
foundation as a series of films i think
there's too much that you have to
condense and too much uh that you would
have to leave out
and it wasn't until the advent of these
big novelistic streaming shows like game
of thrones that i thought oh maybe
maybe this could work because
now instead of trying to figure out how
we can do it in nine hours you know
three three hour movies
in success maybe i can figure out how to
adapt it over the course of 50 hours or
60 hours or more yeah and you are aiming
everyone knows it you're aiming for how
many seasons i do i am i am aiming for
eight doesn't mean we'll get there okay
uh doesn't mean i'll change my mind or
i'll say i give up uh but um
yeah i think it was such a big gamble on
behalf of
sky dance and apple
that they wanted to know
that i was writing towards something
that we were writing towards something
that i wasn't just vamping so i did have
to take them through about an hour or so
broad strokes of
in success where the story would go and
and where would it go given that asimov
himself didn't finish it right right and
when you are adding these things i mean
cloning the emperor i think is a
wonderful idea and also we can
imagine that's something that asimov
would have done if he had thought that
and you know been in that
trying to do something like that i mean
how well that's just it that just did i
mean
i mean
nanotechnology
this kind of cloning uh i mean that that
wasn't something that was being talked
about or even possible in 1948 and i
imagine if you were writing it now he
would have uh
you know
um embraced science fiction concepts
like that so i guess that's my question
are you literally trying to put yourself
into the mind of isaac asimov when you
add these things or is it just that
you're saying well here are the themes
we're trying to get across that come
from asimov's book let's just see how we
can fill in the story to make that
happen
i would say it's a little of both
when when i'm adapting something what i
try to do is i try to identify the core
elements or concepts that make
um
the property
you know
unique that that make foundation
foundation right and and
um in the if if the author or originator
of it is still alive i'll bounce those
off of him or her in this case i bounced
them off of
robin and i said here are the things
that i think make foundation foundation
uh
and
and as long as we
if we agree
then a we're um
uh you know it's like we're eight we're
each
at least we're agreeing that we're each
accepting the same model of reality
right or the same you know we're the
same model of the universe if you don't
agree then there's then there's trouble
but in this case uh robin
uh and the estate felt that yes it seems
like you've nailed the fundamental
concepts and then i said okay well
here are some things uh given
well that's the other challenge right
the other challenge is when when
foundation came out
70 years ago the audience was completely
different
much less the world was completely
different so he was using science
fiction as
kind of social allegory and he was the
empire yes he was
basing foundation on the you know uh the
decline and fall of the roman empire but
the empire that he was interrogating
with his metaphors was a post world war
ii uh environment it was you know the
empires that were falling with the
realignment of
of europe at the ascension of america
the ascension of the soviets things like
that that's that's what he was writing
about well that's a that's not the world
that we live in today
um
so i had to
think about well
what are empires that are falling today
and that leads you to everything that's
happening
i'm not saying it's political but the
rise of nationalism climate change
uh the metoo movement
things like that um i mean that's just
we're watching a big realignment right
now
and um
you know the old guard is being
challenged
but the but the other thing is that the
audience has changed right so the
audience that were reading his original
stories in astounding
science fiction were largely men largely
white men
the field of science fiction was almost
entirely dominated by white men
and um you know even if you
you
looked at the original stories you know
that were being written by asthma oven
himself or there were there were
virtually no female characters
whatsoever in the first foundation but
i'm not even sure that there were any
speaking female characters
so
it seems obvious now but but but you
know that the audience consuming this
is much more varied than the audience
that was consuming foundation when it
came out and it seemed insane to me
that especially because we're
we're contemplating galactic empire that
exists 25 000 years from now that the
that the uh the characters in the show
wouldn't be reflective of the audience
that was consuming it do you know that
famous clip of carl sagan on uh the
johnny carson show complaining about
star wars being all white men back in
the 70s well and that strikes uh close
to home because carl sagan is my um
wife's um uh was my wife's godfather
so wow so there's a there's a connection
there uh uh annie druyan is is is my
wife's godmother so oh okay cool yeah i
and and asimov himself
talked about that later in life and some
of the subsequent books he introduced
more uh female characters but you have
some purists that are extremely upset
that we dared to
genderflip uh some of the characters
that we you know they're accusing us of
doing a woke adaptation of the book
i tend to think that
you know this is getting off topic but
that's okay uh i tend to think that
people are just out there
waiting for things to be adapted so they
can express their outrage that it is
varied in some way from the original
thing it's become just a tool in the
culture wars rather than a legitimate
honest reaction sometimes
i i don't disagree but also i mean we
live
in a time of outrage culture i mean
that's everything
that social media is stoking it's
outrage is the coin of the realm uh i
mean we know now between with twitter
and
and and facebook that negative posts
gain more
traction you do so you do it's uh
we're uh
you know this is the era of outrage and
i hope we survive it well this is why
i'm i'm very happy to be a pretty
successful but never absolutely top
podcaster because i am not trying to
stoke outrage uh with the episodes here
there's better ways to go and speaking
of which uh there's an obvious uh
issue that raises itself when you
adapt foundation not only that it's a
sprawling story and the characters are
different in every part but there's a
lot of science and math there are a lot
of scenes where there are people sitting
around a table talking about math this
does not lend itself immediately to the
kind of cinematic spectacle we're used
to now so how did you think about that
challenge
it's true it's uh
you know solving math problems or
debating statistics are not particularly
cinematic or not particularly dramatic
um and
and i know that the die hard fans
are a lot of people that are um
you know either scientists themselves
who are familiar with science
and uh
do you know the phrase uncanny valley
when dealing with you know um
i mean i first heard of it i don't know
if it originated here with with
animation with computer animation yeah
and
so i don't know
you know the idea being you know when
when zemeckis was doing things like
polar express or beowulf these motion
capture um
uh
animated films uh the the animation was
getting good enough that it was almost
realistic
but but but there was something about it
that was uncanny that that creeped
people out and so
they decided that a lot of people
decided that better to do a more
stylized kind of animation that you can
actually
invest in the characters more easily
than sort of reaching you know
99
realistic somehow is worse than 70
realistic so anyway when dealing with
science
and math and things like that in a show
um
i call it you know almost the the
uncanny valley of of adapting science
which is to say
that you
you
i appreciate science uh uh i read a lot
of science magazines and articles and
books and i i listen to your podcasts i
listen to other science podcasts
and i'm always trying to work more
scientific accuracy into my work and for
in fact i work with a organization
called the science exchange
um which is attempting to do just that
uh with the national academy of sciences
which is partnering
uh filmmakers with scientists and trying
to um get more scientific accuracy in
these depictions well i know well
while we're speaking of our wives my
wife jennifer willett was the founding
director of the science entertainment
well there you go oh my god i didn't
even realize that okay so i i i
okay i i have to
go off into a tangent for one second
which is i went to one of these first
um
uh mixers i guess and one of the things
that was really remarkable is you know
there were maybe 10 or 20 of us uh
creators that were partnered with
various um experts in their fields and
and the creators that were there we all
just thought we're you know
a bunch of knuckleheads listening to
these incredibly
passionate and brilliant people talk
about uh their work they were doing
presentations on their work
and and you know it one of the mixers
we're all having a couple of drinks
you know
uh in us and and and we were saying why
are why are you here you scientists you
know you guys are legitimate you guys
are saving the world
and to a person one of the things that
they said was
because the reason i got into science
was because of star wars or star trek or
and and i and and the little light bulb
went off on all of our heads and we said
wow there's there's a service then that
we can provide and it's not even like
star wars was even remotely accurate or
star trek wasn't that accurate either
anyway
uh and and and that that sometimes gives
me some hope and maybe we're inspiring
you know a few
random young people to get into science
if if we were able to do that with you
know foundation then that in and of
itself made it worthwhile
anyway back to the uncanny valley
so i'm trying to work math and science
into this i've got some science advisors
on the show uh
uh kevin hand you know who works with
jbl and nasa's on the show previously
podcast guest
oh oh okay i i need to look up this
episode so love kevin uh gotta had a
couple other um mathematicians advising
us
and um it's tricky because
it it's not like there aren't moments
you know when where we've depicted
something where
i know it isn't exactly accurate i i'm
aware that it isn't exactly accurate
because i've had my science advisors
tell me that it isn't the problem is
sometimes the exactly accurate way of
doing it is just boring or just boring
when you're depicting it on screen right
and
and
then we will have these other drafts
where you know in in episode five we got
the scene where she's one of the
characters gail is trying to use optical
navigation to sort of figure her way out
of this
um problem and and i understand that in
and of itself that's a relatively simple
thing you know that's you know discussed
you know in in terms of of navigation
but it's not for the mainstream audience
and so what we depicted was an
incredibly dumbed down version
of it and i knew we were depicting it
and even so
um you know
the various stakeholders in the show
were saying can you trim it down can you
cut it back and cut it back and i knew
that that was the most dumbed down
version possible and so
you know it's that's what i call the
uncanny valley is where you you
you know or
we can get into we're we're traveling
from stardust our you know planetary
system to planetary system and i'm aware
of the fact that you know these ships
would have to travel faster than the
speed of light and we would get into
issues of relativity
but
um
at a certain point you just have to kind
of hand wave it and say
you know that being said i do i do want
to correct myself in in one podcast
someone said how long did it take for
the slow ship which is this ship that um
harry and his uh people take to terminus
and we've said that
tranter is in the center of the galaxy
now if i remember correctly isn't the
galaxy about 106 light years across or
something like that oh no it's thousands
or thousands of light years really oh my
god well we got even that wrong anyway
but so but obviously the what they call
the slow ship it's supposed to take five
years
to
get from the center of the galaxy to the
edge of the galaxy
and
and the only way that the slow ship
could get from the center of the galaxy
to the edge of the galaxy is to travel
faster the speed of light i believe yeah
that you can correct me if i'm right now
that way it's definitely right yeah yeah
so um
so that means
that the slow ship is traveling faster
than the speed of light well what i've
said in the show is that only empire can
fold space only a empire so we did have
a scene in which empire sets up these
sort of predetermined jump gates that
these slower ships go to and then jump
incrementally anyway it got cut out but
on a podcast on on on another podcast i
said that it was traveling something
like half the speed of light and and a
bunch of
science people threw up their hands and
said that's wrong that's wrong and it is
wrong and i all i can say is i just
flown in from prague that morning i was
incredibly jet-lagged and i got it wrong
you know i'm 100 on your side in this
one and i will advise you to never go
see a science fiction movie in the
company of a bunch of physicists because
sure i'm sure because they're just
laughing and intentionally from the
place
yeah that's right but it does raise an
interesting story
or an interesting question because i
mean like you say uh it has an
enormously influential
uh reach these these big movies i mean
the way i like to say look if i write a
book uh i can try to get everything
right in my book and i'll reach if it
all goes well tens of thousands of
people and they will really understand
something learn something about science
but a tv show or a movie uh will not try
to get it exactly right but will reach
millions of people so you know there's a
different role for that to play and and
i mean so i i guess you've already
answered this in some extent but i
wanted to know you know how do you
balance the
getting it right versus what serves the
story
well that's that's just it right that's
the tight rope you have to walk i i mean
foundation is is already being received
by an audience in the millions yeah you
know the show
far beyond anyone who's currently read
the novels i mean you know that's a tiny
tiny tiny subset of our audience
and so you ask yourself well then you
know
if we if we have to take some artistic
liberties is it is it worth it and i i
would argue
it is is it worth it if we can inspire
some people to go into science i would
say yes is it worth it if we're telling
a show that's fundamentally about
faith in reason and faith in science in
this era i would say yes it's incredibly
worth it i mean that's
we we need our scientists right now and
this is a show
that says it's only through science and
reason that the human race is going to
survive
i i think i've told the story before on
the podcast but it's so suitable here i
once was doing a consult for a movie
like many movies one that never appeared
as you're i'm sure very familiar with
the phenomenon
but uh they came to
my office at caltech to talk to not only
me but some of my graduate students and
you know they wanted all these opinions
for my students and so they said well
here's the scenario for the movie and
the students are instantly like no that
would not happen
yeah yeah and we had to say well that's
not a helpful response i mean you have
to
and the light bulb went on for them when
i said
what you're being told when you're told
the movie script is not a theory of
physics take it as data
yes this happened like it or not and now
your job as the scientist is to come up
with an explanation that makes it all
make sense and then they they all got it
right it was like they were having a lot
of fun bouncing that around i think that
can be the role of the science
consultants to really just not say this
is right this is wrong but here's how
you make the story make sense and that
serves the purpose of telling a good
story well i i i'll give you an example
right so there's there's a place in
season one no spoilers that
that harry selden is from a place called
helicon
and um
that ostensibly orbits a dark star which
is i guess
a black hole or a brown dwarf or
something like that uh and and that
ostensibly this world is sort of in an
accretion disk and
it's it's not a very hospitable place uh
to have a planet
and in kevin hand our our consultant
said
it wouldn't really work and and on top
on top of it
this is a tiny preview of next season
but on top of it i said
i i want to i want there to be a moon
that's incredibly close to the world
that's so close that they share an
atmosphere and he said there's no way
that would happen because the tidal
effects of the moon would just create
these ridiculous sort of you know you
know winds and and then on top of it you
know the the radiation and whatnot from
the black hole or brown dwarf
everyone would have to live underground
there's no way there's no way there's no
way
but i i just said he would say why do
you want it and i said well for all of
these visual reasons and it's important
metaphorically and and it looks
interesting and whatnot
but
he said well i suppose if you invoke
some kind of type 2 civilization
engineering i said well that's great
because
you know the the galactic empire is a
type 2 civilization and so
so he said well yeah if you had you know
this whole array of satellites on one
side they were helping with the gravity
and you did this and did that and i said
great done you know
we're adding all of those things but but
um and it's certainly going to make
when we get to season two some really
arresting
and exotic visuals
well i think that's the right attitude
that's the right strategy for handling
science advisors which is never to take
the first no for an answer you know just
push them on it and they're like well
okay then you could do this and then
often i think that leads you to some
place more interesting because you know
the real world is made of constraints
and drama is all about overcoming
obstacles and science can give you some
good obstacles to overcome
yeah absolutely and it certainly led
us time and time again into some really
interesting um
you know
storytelling uh iterations you know we
did we have many times
changed our story based on the advice
we've gotten from our science advisors
in some cases we've just corrected
things in the dialogue but in other case
cases it's led us to
tell a more interesting kind of story
because constraints in storytelling are
fascinating and interesting constraints
um can
inspire you to take a more creative
approach to something and constraints
are interesting
for the characters to have to navigate
their way through absolutely yeah
speaking of constraints um
along these same lines you know the
foundational idea for
pardon the pun of the original stories
was psycho history right yes um i mean
parenthetically i i do think that psycho
history is entirely bs i don't think
that there will ever be something called
psycho history in fact i'm writing a
book uh about the physics of democracy
where i explain why asimov was mistaken
about that but you know for the purpose
of the book i think it's perfectly fine
um
how do you or do you just not
dramatize uh sitting around and thinking
about math is that something that is
intrinsically unfilmable or is it just
you make it pretty without worrying
about explaining it or do you sort of
shift it on to
more character based ideas
all of the above i mean one of the first
things we did
you've seen the show is
our depiction of mass i think math i
think is incredibly beautiful and um
and i think it's unique in in terms of
filmed entertainment and
um i remember when we were developing
that we did a lot of look development
and um a visual effects house a design
house called tendril were the ones that
cracked it
but i i talk a lot when i'm talking to
my um
fellow filmmakers and department heads
and whatnot
i'm a story guy fundamentally so i i i
talk in adjectives or i
you know i'll be emotionally descriptive
and i said i want our depiction of the
math to be very beautiful and i want it
to look like the language of angels
that's what i said what does that mean i
don't know you figure it out and come
back to me right uh and and and i said
you know i didn't want to use arabic
numerals because that was i didn't want
it to look like the depictions of of
nash's work in a beautiful mind i wanted
to see obvious comparison yeah yeah
exactly something beyond that
and we came up with this um
depiction that's that's you know our
it's it's swirling and it and and it's
beautiful and and the math
you know swoops and spirals and it's
somewhat based on kind of the
murmuration of birds or starlings or
things like that
and
and it's it's meant to be beautiful
and god-like because i often think that
that if angels spoke i'm not
particularly religious they would speak
in math because it's sort of the code
that the universe is based on
and and so that's quite beautiful uh
that when we see the math and the
depictions of psycho history
um
but then my other way of approaching it
or our other way of approaching it
was
to not talk about
the dryness of the predictions but talk
about how the predictions relate to the
people in the story
so
some people are fearful
some people are hopeful
some people believe that the predictions
are are being misused or that harry's
become a cult leader and then there's
also this whole idea of
are are are they predicting
a deterministic future you know are they
depicting a future they can be changed
or they can't be changed do we have any
free will does an individual have any
agency that stuff's interesting right
right and and that's those are some of
the things that we traffic in in the
show and we'll traffic in the show again
and again and again is is the math our
salvation
is the math our damnation are we
prisoners of the math
all right now you got me thinking about
this i gotta these these are very good
questions um but also at a stylistic
level as you said about asmos original
text uh
not only were the characters all
men and and you know there was not a lot
of ethnic diversity talked about whether
it was there i mean maybe he didn't yeah
to my knowledge most of the characters
that they the
the ethnicity ethnicity wasn't was
interesting
right but it implied that it wasn't very
diverse but it's also um you know he was
not talking he didn't have a lot of sex
scenes and he didn't even have a lot of
uh action scenes or or battles or
anything like that and i think once i
read an interview with him saying that
he didn't have any bad guys you know it
just he just had you know problems that
the universe was giving you so that's
that must be part of your toolbox to add
and spice things up a little bit well
and in fact the
the protagonists
uh certainly of the the the first novel
and the second novel by and large
also don't have any conflict
you know they're fully formed and most
of them don't have any doubts and and
just when you're watching filmed
entertainment that is simply not
interesting i mean filmed entertainment
it's based on conflict we want to see
peop people
doubt themselves and and overcome those
challenges we want to see them fail
um
we want to see
soap operas to a certain extent we we
want to see people fall in love and fall
out of love and betray one another and
and and that
that's filmed entertainment uh no one
would have made an adaptation of the
show that was simply
men in a room
sort of smugly self-satisfied having
thought of you know thought of the the
answer you know and and then presenting
it to other people and and not having
any dark night of the dark nights of the
soul no one would have made that show uh
and
perhaps a tiny tiny sliver of the
audience might have loved that version
of the show but
it never would have been made
well it's interesting because despite
you know my formative science fiction
reading years being in the 70s i read a
lot of stuff from the 30s and 40s the
pulp era
and it certainly was part and parcel of
the
style of uh heinlein and campbell and
asimov that there were competent men
solving problems and that's the least
the great man theory yes very very very
very much and you know i still
like
the competent side of things you know
the competence porn aspect of i don't
like my characters being stupid but
that's i guess that's i'm putting words
in your mouth but
characters can be flawed and make
mistakes without being stupid and that's
the kind of thing you're looking for
right
by and large yes although you know i'm a
fan of succession right and succession
uh has a lot of characters in it that
are flawed and
and stupid yeah
that's not another thing
it's a brilliant show
i've just a question for you uh you know
working in the rarefied uh
field that you do
can you enjoy
uh
a work of soft science fiction or you
know just as a as an audience member can
you enjoy it oh 100 yeah no i have no
trouble whatsoever
uh violating laws of physics or or
inventing complete fantasy uh the two
things that bug me are not making sense
and like i said just total incompetence
purely for story reasons like this
person has to be dumb to make this event
happen and like right you just weren't
working hard enough as a writer there
i'll tell you something that i can't
remember
someone might have taught this to me
or
perhaps i'm
remembering it incorrectly but when
we're in the writer's room
one of the things that i'll say
frequently is and which is not to say
that we sometimes we have failed but
that that i hate coincidences that work
in the favor of the protagonists that's
just bad storytelling however
i think coincidences that work in favor
of the antagonist
and that make it worse for the
protagonist
i think are okay because you know i you
always want to make it as difficult for
your protagonists as possible and so i i
do think an occasional coincidence that
works to the favor of the villain is
permissible
yeah in fact i think that's exactly
right i'm on board with that it's the
self uh harm that i that yes that wine
bugs me but that's another example okay
uh have you seen breaking bad oh yeah
okay very very
better
right both both are incredible
incredible shows and you know walter
white or um you know saul goodman
bo in both shows frequently self-harm
themselves i mean they both trip over
themselves
and and
part of
the
fun of that i won't say fun but but but
part of the reason i think you you watch
those shows you say oh please don't do
that please don't do it please don't do
that but the fact of the matter is that
human beings work against their own
self-interest all the time no it's true
all the time anyway i'm just i'm just
arguing against your equivalent no i
mean i i get it and in fact this is one
of the
i think that's what
stopped uh
breaking bad for me one of my all-time
favorite shows but on the other hand he
was super competent at his domain
expertise right you know he was the best
chemist around so like when he got to
that
he he could shine
one of the things that we're
playing around with
in the latter half of the season as a
preview on foundation um and then
in future seasons are are the sort of
yes i mean harry selden is the
consummate domain expert
um
but he has his shortcomings yes his
personal shortcomings and we're going to
uh and they're a product
of his experience and a product of his
um
his childhood and we're going to start
to explore those uh and and
they do inform his math and they did
inform psycho history and so
but that's interesting as well and
certainly something that that asimov
wasn't interested in exploring no we
didn't learn a lot at least in the
original series in the original original
choice yeah that's right um
so
this all brings up like a bigger picture
question maybe you have thoughts about
this or maybe not but science fiction
of that era and maybe even today has a
self-image of being the literature of
ideas right you know this is where
even if you're not trying to you're not
tr in fact you're not trying to predict
the future but you're trying to imagine
the future in different ways it can be i
mean how much does a creative person
like you take that on board as a duty to
sort of be the literature of ideas
i do i mean fundamentally i would say my
job as a storyteller is is first it's
that you know do no harm with
storytelling it has to
be
a watchable show it has to be a show
that people want to tune in
week after week so that
that's my first job you know is is to
make
people want to keep watching uh
selfishly for me
it's because i like working in this
medium and and i'm a big nerd and a big
geek and that means if i can keep
watching the sh
if i can keep making the show
then i have an opportunity
to depict black holes in the future i
have an opportunity to sort of depict
some of these other things like a space
elevator following that i've always you
know read about and dreamed about
depicting and i i like doing that stuff
i like telling the kinds of stories that
that can only be told with the kind of
boundaries or complications
yeah i am interested in in in
in telling a story about you know
relativistic time i i am interested in
in
in depicting all of these things or
figuring out what happens you know prior
to the big bang or depicting that you
know on the show yeah and so the only
way that i can get to do more of that is
if the show's successful and a big
enough audience watches it so but i i do
take it seriously i do think
as the show progresses i'm i'm
interested in
in and depicting um
you know
what are the social politics of the
future what are the gender politics of
the future and you know um
uh
what happens in the future when you can
you know
not just clone people but you know
predict you know
not predict but assign gender
perhaps there are three four or five
genders you know that that we can assign
and so all of that i find interesting
and and and so i do think
part of the sort of remit of the show is
to get our audience to think about some
of these big ideas and some of these big
concepts well i know that in the movie
business there's been worry both about
the economics of the giant blockbusters
and also the
prevalence of you know comic book movies
do they even count as cinema as martin
scorsese has argued and so forth um and
the economic worries aside you know
you've done both the comic book stuff
and and this science fiction stuff which
is a little bit different so i guess uh
do you consider this idea again i'm
trying to put words in your mouth i
shouldn't do that
one might argue that uh thinking about
the large-scale sweep of the future of
human history is just as important as
talking about someone middle-aged and
breaking up
right i mean that's just as human and
real and and dramatically
relevant um
are there worries in your mind or do you
even care about uh does it is it as
significant from an artistic point of
view to be telling these big space opera
stories
i i understand what you're asking um
am i worried that that my little show
our little show won't be taken as
seriously when it comes to you know
awards season
uh it's one way of putting it right
exactly yeah no uh i'm not i mean
i mean there are tens
historically there's been kind of a a
snootiness um when it comes to genre um
both in film and television historically
um
science fiction and fantasy are not
genres that have been held in high regr
regard at least beyond the sort of what
they call the technical awards
but that started to change with game of
thrones at the end of the day no i mean
i
i um
i think even in the first season we get
into some pretty heady
philosophical stuff
um
and uh
what's interesting for me is that we get
into some pretty heady philosophical
stuff in a way that and and i adore
breaking bad but in in a way that they
never could or would
and i think that's kind of unique about
our show and i think people will be
surprised when they get to the end of
the season at
for a show that was based on
relatively dry hard
series of relatively dry hard science
fiction stories i my hope is that people
will be surprised at just how moved they
end up being yeah and how thought
provoking some of it is and you said
you've seen the first season so i'm
alluding
to episode 8
which i
i think is pretty intense yeah and i
would argue is in terms of just as
essential questions is about as intense
as it gets uh by the end of that episode
uh and and you know we've already
written season two and we
part of the fun of season two is we've
gotten through the exposition and there
are some extremely
interesting philosophical questions that
we get into as essential questions in
season two but but also even in this
season
as the season progresses we get into the
nature of denmarchel who is a humana
form robot and whether or not dem result
is a is a being
uh whether or not denmarchelle has a
soul
um whether or not demarzel is a machine
or or you know
she it is not a biological life form but
whether or not she it is a life form
and we get into some of the interesting
constraints of of asimov's laws of
robotics as well and
i i think we go to some some pretty
rarefied philosophical places in this
show yeah no that's a very very good
answer but you know since i do have you
here let me lean on your domain
expertise a little bit and talk about
the
you know the what goes into making
something like this like first at the
most basic level you already alluded to
the fact that it could have been done as
movies
doing a tv show is just a very different
thing on the one hand you have a lot
more room to work on the other hand
something's got to happen every episode
like how do you balance that do you
think it's more freeing to do the tv
show or is it more like
demands on you to have so many
cliffhangers or twists or what have you
both i will say i started out working
almost exclusively in film and over the
years i've started to gravitate more and
more towards these serialized uh shows
that are happening on the streamers
my
personal preference for
these days consuming something tends to
be
long-form serialized narrative yeah i i
like
digging in and knowing that i could be
with characters for multiple seasons i
love the experience of watching game of
thrones and
knowing that care you know in a movie
you can usually have a character change
once and it happens fairly quickly right
it has to happen over the course of two
hours or three hours
but
but you know in a in a 50 or 60 hour or
70 hour serialized show
characters can grow and change and fail
good people can become bad people bad
people can become good people they can
screw up multiple times and and
i just find that kind of storytelling
jazz more interesting personally these
days
but it does come with its constraints as
you say uh people like their
cliffhangers
there's a cadence
to the way people consume storytelling
uh these days that
comes with its own set of um assumptions
and and i've been experimenting
with
not sometimes going with that cadence
you know in this show and sometimes
people are upset that
you know we'll be with the character for
a couple of episodes and then we won't
get back to them for a couple of
episodes or that we'll
we'll slow things down and do a short
film at the beginning of an episode and
i that's very deliberate on my part and
um it's interesting because i think some
of that comes from the audience being
unconsciously trained by watching things
like game of thrones very much game of
thrones which was i thought a brilliant
show but wasn't experimenting with the
forum quite as much as we've been
experimenting in season one some people
love it some people don't but i i'm
cognizant of that the other thing that's
interesting
um just in terms of the way it's being
consumed
is
different netflix releases all their
shows at once right uh
hbo max has been experimenting with real
recently releasing them two at a time or
four at a time or something like that
when we started producing this apple
hadn't even existed as a streamer and so
they hadn't decided how
their shows were going to be consumed
ultimately they decided that they felt
that they can create more water cooler
moments if the show comes out on a
weekly cadence
on one hand that's infuriating
for the audience who are used to consume
who are used to binging things right and
some of our audience have been very
angry that the show is that we're daring
to release the show on a weekly cadence
but they're talking about it and so i'm
just as a kind of social scientist
i'm really interested to see you know we
just released episode six this uh
weekend we've got four more this season
i'm really curious to see what the
experience of the audience is and how it
differs when you're watching it once a
week or how
an audience will experience our show if
they can just binge it once it's you
know
once thanksgiving is out and they can
watch all 10 and new people are coming
to it i'm just really curious to see how
what their perception of the story is
like and how that changes from consuming
it on a weekly cadence now i think it's
a great question and i will say you know
to the listeners out there who are
thinking about watching it um
number one i i would my advice would be
to come at it as a completely new
experience if you've read the books you
know don't don't try to
shoehorn it into the books like accept
it for what it is uh because it is a
completely different thing and the other
is you know i i actually think and we'll
see how this goes but i think that your
season one is like
the paradigmatic case of something that
would be much better to watch over two
nights rather than over ten years
i suspect you're probably right yeah and
it probably works better you know two at
a time or three it's you know three at a
time or not um you know that decision
was just above my pay grade of course uh
so uh and people can't always wait right
people don't have to watch it every week
yeah but it'll be interesting though
once
i'm just really curious to see what
happens once thanksgiving hits then over
the course of the next three months
because inevitably more people will come
to it
they've been hearing about it and how
that changes and then the question is
when we get to season two
and our audience has been building you
know
does apple decide to stick to their guns
and release it once a week or not i mean
game of thrones was very successful
coming out once a week on the other hand
i think season two will be easier for us
as storytellers because
a lot of the big exposition
you know
we've gotten over that hurdle and and
now we can quote just tell the story
yeah but i do think uh again apple will
do what it does it's certainly beyond my
pay grade if not yours um
but
your storytelling techniques in this in
the show are more formally inventive
than game of thrones was it's a
different kind of thing and it just
helps the audience a little bit to you
know remember what happened from moment
to moment you can watch it
very quickly the other thing that will
happen which is interesting is
season one the show comes out so a
from the die hard fans there's an
expectation of what an adaptation of
foundation should or shouldn't be
um
after seasons come by the time we get to
a second season
um we're not dealing with those
expectations anymore hopefully we're
just dealing with it is what it is yeah
uh
the same will be said you know prior to
the show coming out a lot of people are
saying it's the next game of thrones or
is it the next game of thrones or it's
game of thrones in space i understand
why they're talking about it but it's
not particularly helpful of course it's
not game of thrones
uh it's not intending to be game of
thrones but hopefully by the time we get
to the second season you know nor was
game of thrones at the beginning uh
people were freaked out when game of
thrones came out because it it defied
conventional storytelling there were too
many characters it was a slow burn
yeah people died uh it also broke some
of those storytelling conventions and
hopefully by the time we get to season
two
uh they won't be comparing it to game of
thrones it will just be foundation has
sort of set this tone and it is what it
is and now they're
they're judging it on its own terms good
uh two questions to wrap up um one is i
can't let you go without at least
mentioning the sandman like if if
foundation wasn't already wickedly
difficult to adapt into an episodic tv
show it's it would seem to me like
sandman is an even bigger challenge is
it uh do you do you feel like you've
practiced now with foundation and it's
gonna be easier or are the challenges
completely unique
uh sam well they are unique they are
both long considered unfilmable you know
the biggest challenge with sandman
is that it it doesn't adhere to any one
genre uh it it skips around it's it's
you know
it's it's a it's a it's a horror episode
it's a philosophical episode it's a
fantasy episode it's a
largely
um historical fiction episode about
you know
i don't know i get you know uh
shakespeare you know in the way that he
wrote uh his plays
where his inspiration came from um some
of them are funny uh some of them are
farcical some of them were deeply
steeped in in dc universe
um
mythology
that was always the biggest challenges
it's it's it's always been a bit of a
feathered fish
it's not easily
categorizable if i got that word right
um
in the case of sandman
uh
the creator is still alive
and it's someone that i've gotten to
know neil gaiman uh over the years and
it was kind of remarkable because for
years i was it's also something that i
felt would benefit from long-form
storytelling that
they were having to cram too much into a
feature adaptation right but was in the
case of sandman
um
i finally convinced warner brothers to
do it as a as big serialized show
and the thing that was remarkable with
sandman is no one had ever thought of
making neil a producer
on the show
uh and i insisted that that be the case
and said i wouldn't do it unless neil
was a producer and then i said i want
neil to co-write
uh the first episode with me so you know
we have that in primitor we have that
stamp of approval
i suspect when the show comes out
um it's it's largely high fantasy so
we're not going to get into issues of
whether or not we've screwed up on
relativity or things like that
but but it's got its die hard fans some
of who are already angry that that oh
yeah casting doesn't adhere to their you
know
their preconception of who or what it
should be
and um i i suspect
largely um
and similarly to foundation we had to
figure out a way to
cleave to
you know the organizing precepts of
sandman what makes sandman sandman but a
way to also make it digestible for a
large-scale mainstream audience who have
not read the source material
and we had to sort of hold both of those
um
you know against one another i suspect
like foundation
i hope
that you know the mainstream audience
will largely like it and and i'm sure
there will be some purists for lack of a
better word who would be very angry that
we dared to collapse these two
characters into a single entity or
you know
that the gender or race of a
a character doesn't uh
fit with you know the original depiction
in the comic books you know i was
surprised when i had seth macfarlane on
the podcast that he admitted he
reads all the comments he is very
invested in like what the audience is
saying online about his tv and his his
movies are you that way or do you just
try to stay away from all that drama
i'm
i read some of them i'm not on social
media i made a decision a long time ago
not to be on social media um
i i know myself and i think i would go
down a rabbit hole too quickly and i
also have a very dry sense of humor that
doesn't translate well uh
you know so you know more
yeah but but um
you know i read some of the comments on
reddit i did an ama on reddit um
uh i i think it's helpful to know the
broad strokes of the audience's reaction
but then
it's also important to remember
one of the things that's great about the
internet one of the things that's
terrible about the internet is is every
voice
you know has an equal megaphone you know
uh and
there's some incredibly you know
we all know there's this incredibly
toxic and virulent kind of underbelly to
the internet and
and in the case of foundation there was
some incredibly misogynistic and racist
things that emerged you know with some
of the casting and so
yeah once you get a sort of smell of
that i have no desire to go down to
4chan rabbit hole you know uh you know
on
on that in that regard good and then the
final question is up to you to say how
much you want to say about it but
the best character in the foundation
series is obviously the mule
uh for those who have not read it we
won't give away too much but like a
singular being in the this universe that
asimov invented and we haven't met the
mule yet uh or are we gonna need to wait
until like season six to meet this
character or is the mule coming soon
uh well it's interesting also the mule i
will say was a character that osmo
created because his editor said this is
boring
uh you've been telling these stories and
and yeah
psycho history predicts that this is
going to be outcome and then we'll have
a great man say well of course this is
what's happening and it's boring
uh and so
um he you know to a certain extent
asthma was listening to his critics uh
his main critic being campbell so he
created the idea of the mule this mutant
that was something that psycho history
could not predict
um and it's exciting because it it it
throws the plan into disarray
the mule i liken to
uh
a scene in game of thrones called the
red wedding that happened in season
three you know uh fans of the books
really wanted to get to the red winning
first and
and benioff and weiss who were adapting
the books said
we need to earn the red wedding and so
the first thing i said to apple
they said is the mule gonna be in season
one and i said no
uh the mule's not gonna be in season one
and here's why i would argue that the
mule the mill happens at the second half
of the second book of foundation and i
think the reason why the mule is so
effective
is
because asimov did that storytelling set
up where there was this expectation
that the selden crisis would be solved
in a certain way and and that psycho
history would work and and and then this
spoiler came in and i don't think the
spoiler would have been as effective if
the spoiler had emerged
in the first book or in our first season
so the mule will not be showing up in
season six
the mule will not be showing up in
season one
uh but somewhere somewhere in between
the mule will show up but i will say
the mule
will and will not show up in the way
that the audience is expecting and i'll
just give you one
fans of the books
something to think about which is
in the books
um
there's a second foundation it's sort of
a surprise but in the books the set you
meet the second foundation and they
already exist
you know they're they've already been
created um and they're introduced as
this sort of
you know late stage act 3 reveal almost
like a deus ex machina in regard to the
mule
well in our show
um we don't have the liberty of just
introducing the second foundation as a
deus ex machina or rather that wasn't
interesting so in our show
you know i'm interested in
showing how the second foundation formed
i'm interested in depicting how the mule
became the mule okay
very very interesting that is something
to think about because i i do think it's
fun
to
you know what what fans should do is
really take seriously
how they would adapt their favorite
properties and then compared to what it
is because it's really hard like you
can't just film what's there in the
comic book or on the novel it's a really
it's a tremendous amount of great effort
goes into doing that
well in the case of the mule in the
books the mule just suddenly we start we
start one of the novellas and the mule's
just a thing and he's already taken over
half the galaxy and we have no context
whatsoever about him and then the mule
destroys the empire off screen
yeah
all right something to think about david
goyer i'm sure you've been doing many
many of these interviews so we very much
appreciate your time thanks for being on
the mindscape podcast and and thank you
for being very gentle with me with
regards to science matters science is
gentle that's it's
[Music]
you